إنها عملية دقيقة للغاية ، وتعتمد هذه العملية
على العمل الاستخباراتي بالإضافة إلى
المعلومات المقدمة من قبل الشركاء ، وأعتقد
أن قدرة سيفل أوتلي على التهرب من هذه
القائمة في وقت مبكر هي أكثر
من مؤشر على التزام الحكومة الأمريكية
بمعايير عالية جدًا من الأدلة قبل
وضع شخص ما  في هذه القائمة ولكن في
النهاية تم
وضعه بالفعل في هذه القائمة ، حيث
أصبح الإرهابيون أكثر
تعقيدًا وأعتقد أن رعاتهم الحكومية بشكل
أساسي إيران قد
اكتسبوا أيضًا معرفة جديدة
وشاركوا فيها معًا
العديد من هذه الأشياء مثل  وجود أسماء مستعارة
وأسماء مختلفة
أمر شائع جدًا ، وكما تعلم
عندما تقوم بنسخ اللغة العربية إلى اللغة الإنجليزية ،
يمكنك الحصول على تهجئات مختلفة
بنفس الاسم ويبدو
وكأنه شخص مختلف ، لذلك
هناك الكثير من الحيل في التجارة
بعضها متطور وبعضها غير
متطور لدرجة أن الإرهابيين
مثل القاعدة ومثل إيران
تعلموا ويستخدمونهم بشكل واضح
حاولوا
التواصل بطرق تهرب من
الاكتشاف ، وهكذا
نجحوا لسنوات عديدة في إخفاء موقع
أسامة بن لادن
وكل هذا يذهب إلى زيادة
صعوبة الحصول على معلومات حول
الإرهابيين وما هي خططهم
حيث قد تكون هجماتهم  من
المهم جدًا لنجاحهم البقاء
بعيدًا عن الاكتشاف قدر الإمكان